[Music]
there are millions of people in this
country who can't vote because they live
in a United States territory in the US
Constitution if you're a US citizen you
can vote for president we have no voting
rights in US federal elections a
territory is not a state they're
controlled by the US federal government
but the people living in these
territories don't have the same rights
as those living in the 50 states for
example thousands of them have served in
the US military but they can't even vote
for president there are currently 4
million people in the situation they
live in the American territories of Guam
Puerto Rico American Samoa the US Virgin
Islands and the Northern Mariana Islands
and this doesn't include the many
uninhabited islands that the u.s.
controls hey guys I'm June and this
Sunday we're gonna talk about US
territories where they are what rights
they have and what rights they don't
have if you didn't know that people from
most territories are citizens you're not
alone only about half of Americans are
aware that Puerto Ricans are also
American so we're gonna start with this
island first Puerto Rico is the largest
territory and was acquired by the US
after the spanish-american war Puerto
Ricans had been citizens for over a
hundred years their status came to the
rest of the country's attention after
Hurricane Maria devastated the island in
Porto Ricans are American citizens but
when it came to aid after the storm many
felt like they were treated differently
here's the mayor of San Juan and Puerto
Rico pleading for help if anybody out
there is listening to us we are dying
president Trump's response to that plea
they want everything done for them
the reason Porto Ricans were pleading so
desperately for help is big
the situation was so dire it's estimated
that over 4,000 people died as a result
of the storm 10 months after Maria a
thousand people were still without power
and thousands were homeless taxation was
another big topic of conversation in
misinformation after Maria Puerto Rico
does not pay federal income taxes
because it has its own system of
self-governance but it does pay and so
do the other territories other federal
taxes including Social Security and
Medicare Puerto Rico and the US Virgin
Islands also pay federal unemployment
taxes the political limbo of Puerto Rico
and the other territories creates a very
one-sided relationship with the rest of
the US Puerto Rico has voted on
statehood numerous times most recently
right before Maria and although voter
turnout was low 97% of those who showed
up at the polls voted in favor of making
it the 51st state but the result of
their vote can't change Puerto Rico
status it's ultimately up to voting
members of Congress to determine the
islands and the other territories
political fate most members of Congress
they couldn't find wommen of math and
they don't want to because it's
completely off the radar in the nearby
US Virgin Islands the situation is
similar about 70% of the territory's
107,000 residents are still without
power more than a month after the storm
made landfall
I have no power in my own home and those
of you in Florida and in Texas and in
other places would not stand for that
but you expect us to stand for it these
small islands were also hit hard by
Hurricane Maria and the devastating
hurricane Irma's I hit right before they
were both category 5 hurricanes so the
impact on the US Virgin Islands has
gotten much less news coverage that
could be because their total population
is fairly small just over a hundred
thousand the US Virgin Islands were
bought from Denmark in 1917 for
strategic military purposes though
they've had over 90 years of
they are still only a non-voting member
of Congress that representative you
heard from Stacy Plaskett she's using
every opportunity to remind politicians
in Washington about the millions of
people in the territories who have had
their rights denied once again the
people who have no vote on this floor
the people who have no say in this
country although they are US citizens
are gonna be left out next we're gonna
talk about American Samoa over 7,000
miles away from the US Virgin Islands
the people here are born on US soil they
can freely visit and live in the rest of
the United States but their situation is
a little different they're US Nationals
not citizens American Samoa is home to a
great many veterans especially on a
per-capita basis as our people enlist at
high rates in the US Armed Forces even
if they move to one of the states they
can't vote they can't run for office and
are prohibited from certain jobs they
really are the most disenfranchised of
the territories now the first u.s. Navy
presence was established here over a
hundred years ago though the Navy
governed the island for decades it
wasn't until 1978 that American Samoa
was granted a congressional
representative and that representative
wasn't actually sent to Congress until
1981 but remember that person can't vote
there's also a debate happening on the
island right now over citizenship some
fear that becoming fully American will
mean giving up certain land rights for
indigenous people opening up a
traditional practice of land ownership
to discrimination lawsuits but others
argue that since they're born on US soil
they should be able to have full voting
rights these claims were denied by a
court in 2015
citing the racially motivated insular
cases these cases established the rights
of US territories over a hundred years
ago describing the people in the
territories as uncivilized non-white
alien races and then there's Guam we
just did a whole series where we
traveled to the island and you can check
out the link in the
it's estimated that one in eight adults
on the island of Guam are veterans
that's one of the highest enlistment
rates per capita in the country but
those that serve and come back to Guam
still can't vote for their
commander-in-chief the United States
president they also have issues
accessing medical care and fly thousands
of miles to Hawaii for services over MC
is the same treatment that any veteran
is getting east of corner you know any
veterans getting treatment in the
mainland in Hawaii we just wanted the
same treatment this burden is also
experienced by veterans in American
Samoa and the Northern Mariana Islands
the people of Guam have a long history
of military service but also fighting
for self-determination the first efforts
at self-governance date back to 1901
soon after Guam became a territory of
the United States this fight eventually
led to citizenship in 1950 now at 70
years later and with only limited rights
there's an independence movement picking
this fight back up if you want to learn
more about that movement watch part 2 of
our series now let's talk about the
Commonwealth of the Northern Mariana
Islands there are 14 islands in this
territory also called the CNMI
the majority of people live on three of
these islands one of these islands
Tinian is where the Enola Gay took off
before it dropped the atomic bomb on
Hiroshima originally language and
culture connected Guam and the CNMI but
since 1898 Guam has been politically
separate in 1983 the CNMI made a deal
with the u.s. for citizenship in
exchange the US military got a 50-year
lease for a small uninhabited island to
practice dropping bombs
the lease cost less than $21,000
now the US military plans to use other
islands for bombing and military
training sites that would be part of a
military buildup in the region which
includes moving 5,000 troops from
Okinawa Japan to Guam authorities and
residents and the Northern Marianas
opposed this plan they're concerned
about the impacts of the bombing on
their native land the environment and at
the local tourism industry the NGO
Earthjustice and other community groups
have filed a lawsuit essentially we're
all in the same boat
we're reliant upon US Congress to
determine our rights we don't have a
vote there so we don't have bargaining
power anything they do that applies to
us it's just hit and miss this history
of US territories is one that's rarely
taught in schools but there's a lot at
stake for the people in the territories
who are treated like second-class
citizens whether it's veterans who have
served in the US military or people
trying to rebuild after losing
everything people who live in US
territories are born and raised on US
soil so shouldn't they have the same
rights as everyone else hey guys I hope
you enjoyed the video if you think other
people should know about the
second-class status of people in US
territories please share this video and
let us know what you think don't forget
to like share and subscribe